intro hey there fellow farmers and
gardening
enthusiasts have you ever wondered how
to grow more while using less water well
you're in for a treat today we're diving
into the world of smart irrigation
systems these clever setups are changing
the game when it comes to watering our
crops and
Gardens so grab your favorite drink and
let's explore how we can save water and
boost our harvests at the same time main
content let's start by talking about why
good water management matters so much
water is precious and we need to use it
wisely in farming and gardening when we
water our plants just right they grow
better and produce more but when we use
too much water we're not just wasting it
we can actually harm our plants and
reduce our yields that's where smart
irrigation systems come in so what
exactly is a smart irrigation system
it's like having a Super Smart Gardener
that knows exactly when and how much to
water your plants these systems use a
combination of sensors controllers and
software to make watering
decisions let's break down the main
parts first we have soil moisture
sensors these little devices are placed
in the soil to measure how wet or dry it
is they're like having tiny weather
stations right where your plants are
growing the sensors send this
information to the main controller next
up is the controller which is like the
brain of the system it takes in all the
data from the sensors and makes
decisions about watering the controller
can be programmed with information about
your specific plants and soil type this
helps it make even better choices about
when to water now here's where it gets
really cool many smart irrigation
systems also connect to local weather
stations or use weather
forecasts this means they can adjust
watering schedules based on recent
rainfall or upcoming hot weather imagine
not having to worry about turning off
your sprinklers when it rains the
software is what ties everything
together it allows you to Monitor and
control your irrigation system from your
phone or computer you can see realtime
data adjust settings and even get alerts
if something needs your attention let's
talk about how these systems use
real-time data to make watering
decisions say it's b a hot dry week the
soil moisture sensors will detect that
the soil is getting dry they'll send
this information to the
controller the controller checks the
weather for cast and sees no rain is
expected it then decides it's time to
water and turns on the irrigation system
but it doesn't just water for a set time
it keeps checking the soil moisture
levels and stops when the soil has
enough water this Precision means no
overwatering and no
underwatering just the right amount of
water for happy healthy plants now you
might be wondering does this really make
a difference let's look at some real
world examples a farm in California
switched to a Smart irrigation system
for their almond
Orchards they found they could reduce
their water use by 20% while maintaining
the same crop yield that's a huge water
saving in another case a corn Farmer in
the midwest used smart irrigation to
increase his yield by
15% he was able to give his crops
exactly the right amount of water at the
right times this led to healthier plants
and bigger harvests even on a smaller
scale smart irrigation can make a big
difference a community garden in Arizona
installed a smart system and cut their
water use in half their vegetables
thrived and they even saw an increase in
their Harvest these systems aren't just
for big Farms or dry areas they can be
useful in any climate and for any size
of Garden or Farm in wetter areas they
can help prevent overwatering which can
lead to plant
diseases in drier areas they ensure
every drop of water is used efficiently
now you might be thinking this sounds
great but isn't it complicated to set up
while it's true that smart irrigation
systems are more complex than a simple
sprinkler they're becoming easier to
install and use all the time many
companies offer Professional
installation
services and once they're set up they
often require less day-to-day management
than traditional irrigation methods of
course no system is perfect smart
irrigation systems do require an initial
investment they also need some
maintenance to keep them working
correctly but for many farmers and
gardeners the water savings and improved
yields make it well worth it as we Face
challenges like climate change and water
scarcity tools like smart irrigation
systems become even more important they
help us use our resources more wisely
and grow food more efficiently and
that's good news for everyone who eats
Alro so there you have it folks smart
irrigation systems a clever way to save
water and grow more if you're interested
in trying out smart irrigation start by
researching systems that might work for
your
situation every Garden or Farm is unique
so find a solution that fits your needs
have you used smart irrigation before or
do you have questions about how it might
work for you let us know in the comments
below and if you found this video
helpful please give it a like and share
it with your fellow plant-loving
friends until next time happy growing
[Music]